ah wakey-wakey time for another day hi
gamers hi we don't like the game [ __ ]
hard and I think they're making it
harder in the next patch because they're
seeing all these videos of people doing
solo and they're like oh that's not
right
yeah I wonder what happens routing that
for Wien boys yeah there's a lot of fog
we're dealing with here here clecos I do
I'll go down I cannot see [ __ ] no this
guy had a bad time
Oh God hello what the [ __ ] I'd like
there's one right under me worried oh
hey there yeah yeah I just finally pop
up next to you yeah let's see if I can
clunk this guy I just never get you I'll
[ __ ] hello
I'm just fine it's fine don't worry no
one worry no one panic I've never
worried for a single moment of my life
so there's all this all goes in the same
room right yeah yeah this next room I am
are we ignoring this little door down
here for now then I'm gonna I'm gonna
open this other door here I'm here
happening stop Bob Bob you lights I'm
setting off fireworks there's like 10
feet away from me you could shine your
light on them when they're that far from
here there's a lot of enemies in here we
got it we got three right here with I
chucked the [ __ ] down there I'm gonna
try and get standing up you friend
what does fog repellent do it just
pushes away the fog down there Shawn you
and me we can take are you [ __ ]
kidding me did you know yeah it's Alamo
every things near us also are you
[ __ ] kidding me
Oh it's all good it's all good my dude
it's all good all good Madhu it happens
I I have to say I'm that was entirely my
fault and I don't know how that one
triggered it's fine like I trying to do
b2 solo is a nightmare of just exactly
that it's like some douchebag who
doesn't ever stretch decides to stretch
right as you're going for it you
couldn't see it cuz
you can't see anything and they're all
shooters there's one of the stairs to
get them I'm picking up a scent ah one
more one more somewhere oh yeah I found
it got it I'm at 57 health already whoa
Oh Shawn do you not know how to dodge no
okay so when you got a bullet come at
you you tap left or right and then hit
shift while you're going there you'll
scoot you'll like that's how you dodge
oh I didn't even know that was a
mechanic oh yes so that's how you died I
was just using regular movements and
dodge dodge oh yeah I know blast of the
face yeah I know that died and dodge is
the thing oh man I would have told you
sooner I thought you knew yeah no one
knows anything again three hours I have
I don't nothing
there's seafoam down here I marked it
right there wait how do you mark things
middle-mouse 57
you got a key card already this is a
security door up here with no alarm
which is nice wait we're wait wait you
found a key card no no key hard door oh
oh you saying what key card number was
it was a red 9:57 I see yeah I wish I
found a key card already that'd be nice
yeah I mean so we've had you this that
would be read with us no alarm huh do we
want to do this whole side door yeah
that leads mean it's kind of the same
area but yeah there might be write them
in there
I'll see you know buddy I don't hear
nobody fog repeller go yeah it's clear
we good boys let's do this door fillers
I'll be right there what's done are we
in right now so this is 16 a yeah 16 we
did get all tomorrow yeah we haven't fun
two-terminal I just was at it yeah I am
we got all the storage anyway so we got
these two doors I mean that's the
ceiling one we can do I think way
decision has been made
yeah we need to keep yeah good old
circles how I miss thee be inside of
them they reward you with more torture
this room does looks a bit I say with
confidence before the door opens I like
that
oh my god I didn't see that well really
always reaching far I haven't seen the
tentacle ones yet I'm like Bambi now
I've always thought oh you want to send
one person in try and get tentacle boy
or do we want to just clear that I like
with Marcos in that's gonna be yeah yeah
the guy down there you left someone here
has 50 plus hours in game so yeah I'm
gonna pop this yeah that boy should be
fine for them pop him like a kernel pop
him like a big juicy zit mmm
this games a lot more hentai than I
thought it was just you wait my friend
guy right here in front of us I see that
little glowy head might have time to go
watch out there are stairs here I have
fallen
oh yeah the pit yeah are there enemies
down there there's two ahead of us left
and right but I can't tell if there's
another one clicking underneath there's
there's three in front of us including
that's there well as well just want to
further down yeah tentacle lady's being
a douche but we can we can get up there
and kill them right I mean we one shot
I'm on yesterday well so if you get
close enough tentacle lady can't you
duck under the liqueurs or is that
basically what it is you have about two
seconds from the first tentacle being
puddle turned around contractual
detection so you do have a small window
okay I may have my shot here maybe no
okay and then your silhouette of you
standing up and backing right
I'm gonna try to get it after it cools
down no it's gone away god damn this
thing's being an [ __ ] can we clear
the two on the bridge yeah yeah you're
right Babur you know I'm up here with
you guys if you want me to go down oh I
thought you fell
yeah there's two on those staircase
she's back tentacles yeah if you want if
you want I think I have to go for it if
you want it if you want it you got this
go for happy that's how you do okay go
cake that's first time ever done that
that's terrifying
[Laughter]
that's my first tentacle I'm a lab I
fought them but I've only ever triggered
them and then fought with guns and stuff
okay well there's two on these stairs
down here I'm gonna try to go around to
the hole there's one here as well behind
you be careful yeah yeah I got the one
on the left here it's right in front of
me okay go am i clear to kill them well
yeah yeah you're clear if you go quick
yep got him okay we're clear here they
did not roll that was really close
no no no I've gotten very good at the
canceling mechanics so right click to
cancel if you ever want to do that yeah
yeah I learned that the hard way sorry
is one of us getting this one right here
I'm just gonna get the one down here I
think I should be far enough away that
should be woulda never mind they're
being real oh yeah course there are two
right here yeah there are why don't you
guys want to join me here for the second
yep Emily will you go on it go and get
those two on the stairs something that's
fine okay I'm ready to go ready when you
are
yeah go go go
Thanks okay alert music no we're fine
no okay we got there's only alert for
like a tenth of a second it started oh
we got two more I can see down this
hallway am I good to kill this one you
you sure chill chill chill you're fine
Wang come on oh yeah make sure it's dead
first
yeah it's fine one more got him [ __ ]
hell we're good key is close to read
something red nine five seven I think
that's the one we need now that's the
work that's for the door behind us
oh yeah wait that is the one we need it
show that room there I have gone through
there it's a one alarm room there are a
slew of items back there there's just
tons Oh
so that's like a loop path yes not okay
hmm so if we need loot that's a pretty
easy door to get through it's only one
there are ten storage boxes in there
wait sir the keycard or this one keycard
door behind us so we we could go through
there now if you want but there's also
gonna be lewd ahead of us yeah I think
we're in a pretty good spot I mean yeah
three of us haven't even used our
century pretty much every month yeah I
didn't place mine at all I'm just
worried about my health but should be
fine we should come across that med pack
yeah usually open this yeah you I you
know oh right there oh my god I thought
that everything was about the would
never I I'm not gonna make a lump that I
don't know I can't womp mark you want
some tools I can get in I'm God yeah way
I'm killing this one yeah you go for it
there's there's still two up here yeah
I'm following you chill chill out chill
there's one below you freaking out I'll
go down I'll go down get those girls
weights right on them weights right on
them I'll match his path on the opposite
side and meet him in the middle go man
go you got it and some some serious
squishing going on dude this is this is
methodical I'm proud of you guys
okay called up near a gun it looks like
last one down here maybe I just popped
the last one up top I believe all right
I think we clear wait absolutely
maniacal that's not the word yeah I
think methodical that he said earlier
was a good one I know you wanted to go
to I was primary I want to do my own
word yeah it's like an English essay
where your teacher will give you like
less marks cuz you thesaurus Internet
help me dude you can I never got less
marks because I was a perfect student
you can use my word just put me in your
bibliography yeah it's like your sources
biography out here mark let me let me
cool you uh thanks man thank you
whoa it's doing a glitch out ham there
we go anybody need heels I can top you
guys off yeah I need I'm at 50
we need purple for Zone or 20 and we
need what was a gray for zone 21 let me
go do 72 I think let me go check Hsu
[ __ ] is alright Hsu five eight three
is in zone twenty so we need the yeah
yes right and purple 164 is in probably
through the override door I bet oh it's
new there but then there's another one
on the other side all right these purple
say the number again I've already
forgotten my memories awful 164 that's
my thing 422 so this is a fight room
right this is gonna be an alarm door
yeah but we don't need to go through
blue at all we don't need 21 we don't
need blue yep doesn't even have a hammer
swung in things no hammers you notice
that there's no animation but then when
you swing your characters just like what
don't use your shoulders swing from the
elbow are you guys gonna set up your
sentries or what where am i setting it
over oh this is baby's first century
hoping your central really
oh yeah it's literally just on these
stairs huh yep should we have more than
one through the door should we have one
on this actually it might behoove ah
- not my love goodbye moving not blow
our load on this door just yet and night
but leave it opened wink wink wink right
okay you hearing me you feelin me you
like it leave it open I get to spit your
flappin and then just put two on each
side of the top of the staircase you
know what I'm sayin
that way when we get the clean walk wink
when we get the key for zone 20 wink
wink wink we'll have a whole other week
wink wink wink door you know what I
think you winked enough I think we all
caught on already good to go no I went
down winking noise your character made
is pretty it was very entertaining to my
ears
alright let's do some security circles
boys make it let's make it real make it
tight okay Wade get over here in his way
I hurt my leg watching Mark fall let's
see where I'm going down baby here we go
not too far everyone in their circles
yeah done alright good job I'm going in
melee style
oh [ __ ] you already going over the
writer they all go left I think they all
went left a lot of them are going left
no one hit me don't hit me I'm up here
don't hit me yeah melee seems to be the
strata it's saves ammo it's pretty good
watch out for the sent that one sentry
shotgun pointed our way oh [ __ ] yeah Oh
big guy there's a big boy yeah a big boy
because Big Bertha no he's not been
treated not down there my century up but
dead so that it doesn't kill us anymore
who found a key card I I have a red key
card from back before it just said need
a blue key card I think okay I caught a
face-full sentry at some point
just been carrying the key cards on them
yeah I mean these guys need to get
through doors to why do we assume that
they wouldn't have the key cards you
know disgusting mutated creatures are
keep our people - okay I know funny and
then no one laughs but I was just sad
because you made a mockery of yourself
and we don't like that we're your
friends
Oh would never make fun of you okay
we're gonna support you we're here
getting your back and you're just
tearing yourself down yes so flagellate
took my family apart we're tearing
yourself apart Lisa there's a there's a
whole lot of thick air down here boys
yeah oh I hear more up here there's like
maybe four hey guys I found the HSE we
need Oh what what I didn't but we can
just pretend that the number on that
one's the right number then get out of
here right how about that Oh
what if we just spray-paint it if
there's any way can't we just do a
museum Oh God it's up okay Alamo just
hammer I'm coming okay I got this one
behind us okay we're good we're good
oh wait no we're not good where's chill
chill chill Oh to the right over by me
net run boys okay we gotta chill I was
right there were four you called it I've
been I've been getting really good at
hearing like distinct voices in the
darkness dude go outside no what's the
last time that you bathed I have bathed
less there's no question I don't know
let your body get its natural oils
yeah don't mean wet wash off your
nastiness I do find that my body is I
won't move my bad my bad
we're good I thought you were closer I
see one left to right from here yep okay
ready whenever you are here we go
I got this one over here I think he's by
himself I think this one's oh no not all
of them no where's the next one it's
dead ahead of this one there's two in a
row here let me see this one under me
here that's glowing right now do you
guys see that one in a bit of an
alfresco situation here Bob
all right you go though and Shawn yep
all right not yet but charging up dude I
see it Bob Gotti I have a an ammo pack
over here
nice there's one right here mark there's
one to the left that's right under mark
right on mark okay you go yeah I'm in a
different place it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine it's
fine
no one pack it's good even after like 50
hours of this I still get tense
okay we need zone 22 which is the other
one yep is it an alarm it is right yeah
these are gonna be double alarms Greg
not that only one point of entry so you
know yeah so we just go set our stuff up
over on the hole in the wall call it
good pretty much yeah because mark and
Shawn could use a little healthy smell
tea okay
crossfire more than meets the eye or
something
crossfire robot Sims guy stand in some
circles already I like it I'll go I'll
go upstairs if upstairs is required left
I'll do middle left I'll do whatever is
left I wasn't listening
okay somebody took my left okay that was
probably I was
is all me just assumed Wade because I'm
usually the one to screw up and over
towards the hole in the wall watch out
boys oh we're gonna go back to the door
watch out there boys up
I went far luck no I'll go oh I'm down
to 69 to health just like I wanted
I'm good on sentry ammo my sentry is
empty
I'm not 24 so who did the work there my
shots were more accurate just saying Wow
they're all the same amount of accurate
I'm open anyway i neva need em oh no we
good oh hi oh Jesus
I hear clicks there law air six clicks
my ears I can do it's in my ears perk it
up I'm at the fire one there's an I'll
go far far just in case as I'm sure
there's one there at 3:30 oh there's
there's two back here there are six
doing these ways oh wait wait wait
there's no there's three more oh yeah
there's actually six yeah yeah yeah
there are that bad ear have Earths
I'm just gonna wait here you get those I
think that if these are not looking all
right that's an option
kill them fast and they're all alerted
watch out there are too many too many
too many too many I don't like you
yeah yeah yeah hate to see how the
second time their [ __ ] Prabhas there's a
lot of bullets to the one I saw their
own shooters yep
aim for the head and in front of me so
if you would crouch I'm about to go down
just hide you'll heal from 0 to 20 maybe
it's so many God I'm dad that's up 1
you're down oh lord I can't get you oh
yeah well let's leave Jack down from in
and go the other way besides it's gonna
put that out there that might have been
my bad it sounds like you guys are doing
well you know it baby yeah you know it
oh wow this was a bad place to jump down
I'm a full executive decision area I
just want like five of them I see foam
there there holy pool there's a couple
over there still another popped another
all right there there's only a couple
left yeah we're good i I I don't deserve
it but thank you dude you know how many
times Wade screwed up and somehow you
stay here I thought I could round them
better but I guess I was too close and
triggered it well that's probably that
whole room maybe I have screwed up
exactly zero times since three oh yeah
this was the big room that would so much
of them's hey now now that honestly
could have gotten WAY worse well there's
more open there's a fog repeller here
the flashlight yeah I like that
range flashlight thanks man
the suction is amazing on those things
hey Bob come here I have ammo for you
get it in me play put what I got
I want you got you got what you got in
in me put it do it I'm a baby no wait
man let me in there
let me in there I'm so proud of that
song I'm glad that come up with duck in
my brain make sense at all
what was the element babies belong in
the boobs or something yeah the baby
goes in the boobs or whatever which is
the part reference I don't even know
remember that don't put that one on it's
from one of your videos or something I
don't know what that name for things I
say responded what'd you say out loud
yeah small penis do you ever the small
penis no you broke up and then we're
like listen I'm gonna go pee and when we
come back I'm not gonna talk about this
anymore all right we're gonna go get
this stuff done if you die I'll be the
last alive until they find me okay wait
you ready yeah there's one kind of close
break it's fine charge out okay three
two one that's just I hear more clack II
climb on one there's a lot of downstairs
you can hit it when it's moving
I don't wanna dead I prefer to be in a
nice calm tranquil state so it doesn't
come back and haunt us is like some kind
of do or something you know okay which
we don't wait I saw my flashlight on
that guy right next to you my deal with
that it sounds like a you problem and I
really think you should handle it
Merrick I just gave you health thanks
man thank you
there's like three still aren't there we
have the clearly to mark yeah I can't
have one proud moment I can't have like
hey I did a thing guys my practice paid
off nah nah it don't matter
uh-oh way to go
somebody made a mad it was good guess
who again are they oh my god so down
here I am down here oh there's one
that's more down still up there there's
two more at the moment I'm coming from
the other side they're right below you I
am going for it here we go ABM oh yeah
I'm swinging around don't worry I'll be
there in a moment
just a moment
don't worry about it your toes okay
yeah well I'm listening on the toast of
what where I'm being blamed for it no
one blame you I wasn't me Wade
yeah no one blame to you no he said toss
boy and you went white me no here Bob
was quiet I came back from the bathroom
man look wait maybe if you weren't
flapping your gums alerting all these
enemies you'd be able to hear that it
wasn't your fault yeah I couldn't hear
the clicking off them because Wade was
so loud that's what it is wait no to
agree with you guys okay so we got the
key dude yeah we're doing it baby it's
it's it's game over time oh my god I
just got somebody just shared my stream
and said my scre markiplier and a few
others are streaming it was a top liner
now
incorporated now I'm a not included I've
named one I'm a few people how's it
how's it taste others yeah they actually
met Sean as a few that it even mean oh
this wasn't we didn't open this so this
is just destroyed because of Wade's
fault
sorry I'm flapping my gums what you say
okay get the job I get that look that
man I'm teething well what what even in
the door you can't say my god alright
well that's okay I fixed it I fixed it I
didn't see that one hey at least you
clean up after yourselves unlike Sean
flappy person
I'm really glad all three of you are
here Sean hey I'm just a few people dude
mark you want a health or do you want to
stay at 20 um I can stay at 24 now marks
a good low health friend okay I found
one seafoam alright okay who's ready we
aiming at my headers now I know there's
shooting at the floor next to you huh
actually waiting Sean you have the you
have the beefiest sentry guns at the
moment in terms of load so yeah we do
I'm glad you know yeah crossfire that
door you can do the door oh yeah yeah
let's stand in some circles nerds
through its three rounds good luck
they're coming from the other direction
the will nice right this one's this
one's going on a journey
I'm going back up I think yeah I'm going
back up okay okay you going back up I
got this one
okay you're coming through the door now
they're coming downstairs here they are
okay yeah ramp up here they come
oh my god I just took so many damages
out yeah there's a lot of them yeah it's
okay
make your shots count and you'll be just
I refuse Jesus Christ
Oh God I refuse no no they're not it's
just in your mind it's all in your mind
you got this everyone but me I'm right
in the pier why isn't that capping it
you know I feel like if you go down in a
circle oh did I not did you do it hey
glad those those centers outside were
really worked out it's something break
wait wait wait don't break it just yet
okay
oh there's something there don't break
it
okay well Tory's numerous just chilling
that's good ups what just good job
century I really think it was my
long-range flashlight that did yeah oh
yeah only used 14% ammo Pro I mean you
were incredibly efficient or you know my
century guys didn't kill anything and
use 40% no I literally got like triple
shot at all when I went down I don't
know what happened oh wow I just I just
stay in the corner from the door hurts
on the door the door turns on the door
whoa John you're not safe there okay yep
down guys wrong with me three hours in
the game sorry you're new I didn't used
to be new well now you are in yours just
came after six hours of gameplay more
blowers some people get good
some people get bed some people call me
Maurice well music people call me
Maurice it's a made-up word I miss so
long range flashlight dude don't don't
it's a trap it triggers them yeah your
flashlight that did that yeah and I like
flashed my flashlight for a tenth of a
second and it's suddenly all hell broke
loose is there door over there just this
one over here that's all right here does
it lead to 20 C Martin yeah I found all
the lockers yeah I'm stairs right I
don't need to double check when I wasn't
looking but you know hey buddy
Kemp settle down there this is the only
one I see here yeah there's one I think
I hear one far left but it shouldn't get
triggered there's two over on the right
it is fine you know I do this I love
every time he kills them there's like a
panic noise and mark just killed two on
his own which was he's awesome but he
can do it so load b1 he's got a free
pass to do whatever he wants I was
big peepee move that's what that is rest
of us I want to his peepee mark do you
want combat shotgun ammo uh you know I
I'm ok we we just got to grab the thing
and then get out that's literally our
last prescription I'm gonna refill pack
my sod this is fun you need you need a
be good no it's good
what you talking about you sure yeah
flashlights on boys so you better have
it cleared weights like the timer
sorry yeah yeah thank you
oh there's a med kit here don't give it
to me I wasted just let me die boys yeah
just I've wasted too many med kits
already semi well it's considered to run
I'm gonna give you this just so you can
get to the end cuz if you don't get the
completion you will I don't think you'll
be able to keep going oh yeah it's more
important for Shona to live in the rest
of us yeah
he's the only one that matters we need
him for c1 actually see ones perfect for
Sonny have a flashlight on yeah you guys
you need the person with the accent to
come through I'm the only one here with
charm I may not have skills that's true
well we're dying and screaming you meet
Lane dude aren't you supposed to have a
particular set of skills or something
that's Northern Ireland or where the
[ __ ] is the thing ya know can we ping it
right here
there has consular in here there's one
right by me oh yeah
bring it I don't know the command we
ping space type exactly what it says
underscore 583 CF right here right here
here so if everyone looks at the map I
mean we all know this except from one of
us basically we're trying to run this
away back to here that's not a deal you
bruised pepper so run south boys alright
let's do this [ __ ] let's get out of here
alright
yeah buddy Oh what the [ __ ] it was fine
everybody in form a file get body heat
it's just some person in like a stasis
unit in there and we're just like
up against her take his Judas and let's
get out of here gross but all right
you've convinced me
I'm gonna close the doors over here you
go the other way all right move no whoa
run run run
tell me where the foam so this pillar
around the pillar just because they're
gonna come through both sides so block
block it up foam those boys no I don't
need one
all right it should be fine five seconds
is longer than I usually last good on
that door wait stop belittling yourself
you're leaving no jokes for the rest of
us it was good it's good buddy not a
marathon huh
yeah yeah it's not a marathon it's a
sprint that's what they say $150 an hour
you don't want to take time even with my
liability we managed to do that a good
one you yeah you did great especially
considering the like how not a lot of
time you put in but also you started out
great
and then you got worse over the personal
level say the ones where I moved I will
take full blame for but the flashlight I
I tapped and there's only one thing
[Music]